how do you survive in a Solo
solo hike Through the Jungle what what
are the different components what are
the different dangers so you said you
had a hammock you had some food what
kind of food by the way are we talking
about uh nuts stuff that won't go bad
because you can't so you can't really
start a fire in the Amazon like I'm a
good fight I mean I camp all over the
place I'm a Wilderness guide starting a
fire in the Amazon is futile in fact a
lot of survival manuals will tell you
don't do it because if you're really
lost it'll break your spirit
you're not going to be able to do it
that's dark yeah they're like don't even
try it
um but you can still get like
hypothermia from if you get wet and you
lay out in the jungle you could you know
you could still exposure can still get
you so you want fire
um I even in the beginning I used to
bring like Ramen noodles which is which
is the nutritional is irrelevant and so
I started bringing like nuts and then
supplementing that with fish which
forced me to become a very good
fisherman and
um now of course JJ knows that he can
like they can cut certain roots and they
bash it up and they put it in the Stream
and the fish just float to the top and
they take with me so like he's got like
he's got all the cheat codes yeah
whereas like I'm sitting there with a
hook and he's like he'll go now find
bait and I go bait
in the most competitive ecosystem on
Earth good luck finding a worm you can't
do it what does JJ do he takes the
machete looks at his foot cuts a slug of
callus off of his heel because he's got
this thick rhino skin nice puts that on
the hook
catches a six-inch fish chops it in half
puts it on a bigger and in 15 minutes
he's got a four foot giant catfish that
could feed a family of 16 and he's happy
I'm sitting there and I'm like I'm gonna
try to like stick a beetle on a on a
fishing hook and like you know do you
have just a line and a hook or is there
a rod too just a line and a hook and
then you you just chop a you just chop a
rod and tie it to the you know you just
chop a little sapling so are you still
able to start a fire or no I like for
the food that I bring to not be fire
dependent sure and so if I have some
nuts I can I can shove in a few enough
calories to get me through the night or
like and leave a fishing line out and
there'll be something there in the
morning
um
but yes I can start a fire but a lot of
times what I'll do is I'll bring a flask
and not with like alcohol but with
diesel and so you have a tuna can and
you put the diesel this is what the
local guys do everything I do you know
I'm sure there's going to be someone
listening to this like how could you do
that and it's like yeah this is what we
do down there sorry uh it's a it's a
tuna can you pour a little bit of diesel
in it it burns slow you light it and you
put your sticks you make your pyramid
over that and eventually that will burn
through the moisture and finally you'll
get a very reluctant little fire enough
to burn you know to make yourself like a
cup of tea or to pour that into the
noodles something
something or you just eat a fish raw how
important is it to stay dry is it
basically impossible it's impossible to
stay dry you're wet all the time you're
wet all the time what does that mean
that means infections are more efficient
yeah
um so yeah I don't know if you saw the
picture in my book where I have the
yellow spots yeah so yeah there's a
picture
with your like entire face consumed with
yellow spots is basically I guess that's
MRSA yep
oh boy yeah uh so how did that happen
what uh what was the infection like and
um yeah and how crazy are you for
letting that infection stay in you for
for a long period of time without
treating it or you had no choice no I I
did have a choice I was 19 years old and
I was taking care of a giant anteater
there was orphaned and this is like my
dream animal yeah and she was mine and
my job was to teach her the jungle and
so when I started like noticing that I
had an infection and that I was I had I
think I had Dengue at the time too I
went back to town
probably picked up MRSA in the hospital
where I got tested
came back into the jungle and then got
progressively sicker and sicker and
weaker and weaker as I was two weeks
three weeks in the jungle and then it
got to the point where my vision went
black and white and I passed out one day
and and I don't know why but at the time
I had shaved that day
and when I woke up the next morning I
couldn't open my eyes because the the
pus had come out of my eyes and out of
my the pores in my face all those little
micro cuts and the pillow was stuck to
my face and
I was stuck up River with no help at 19
years old and also when you when you see
that picture you can imagine that I
assumed
that my life was over because I didn't
know what it was and I also didn't
assume that or at the very least I
figured I'd be disfigured the rest of my
life I didn't think there was any
getting better from that
and so I remember sitting by the side of
the river praying that a boat would come
by but it was the rainy season there
aren't going to be any boats because the
river's psychotic
um and so
it was a long time before I got back to
town and I didn't want to leave the
anteater but it became like I was like I
realized I was dying
and then I finally got a boat
with some loggers a death boat just
loaded with these guys were had had gone
into the jungle and shot everything they
could and taken all the babies and they
were gonna go sell them and so it was
like baby monkeys and toucans and birds
and cages and pieces of crocodiles and
Anaconda skins and jaguar skins rolled
up and it was just like I was just
laying there with all these dead animals
in the boat with all the Flies on my
face and
got back to the hotel called my mother
said please book me a flight out like
today like today and then I sat on the
plane and somebody somebody sat next to
me on the plane and I had a hood on and
I do I do remember that in my in the
haze at this point I was having trouble
staying conscious but I do remember that
she like looked over like trying to see
what was sitting next to her and then
she got up and never came back
and when I got to to immigration in New
York you know the cop what he like takes
my passport and he goes yeah he goes so
what were you doing in Peru he's looking
down and he goes yeah and he like holds
up the passport looks at the password
looks on my face he goes Bo buddy
and I said no that's why I was like I'm
trying to get home to go to the hospital
he goes He stamps it he goes go go go go
go God bless God bless he was like oh
[__] yeah and then they put me in the
room in the hospital with like the
hazmat suits and they didn't know what
it was and I spent like five days on IV
antibiotics with like four different
things running through my veins and the
the doctors were like
Don't Let It Go that close they're like
you went real close on that one yeah
that's what that picture I mean people
should uh check out the book just to see
the picture because I imagine you just
laying there unable to see have a fever
probably so you're like half
hallucinating yep
and uh there's no there's no boat
there's no no way out there's no help
coming
um plus there is this creature who
you've become a parent of yeah that you
love yeah
boy that's a dark place to be as a 19
year old I mean most people have never
will never be in a place like that like
where did you find strength in that in
those in that place I don't know I just
remember writing like a goodbye letter
to my parents because I said if I die
out here it was really dark like it was
it was it was terrifying it really felt
like it was the end
and I was writing you know if you find
me out here I'm sorry and all that all
that type of stuff and it was you know
um I don't know about strength there's
no strength it was just like move
forward and at some point it was like if
you'll take me down river take me down
river you know and
you just got lucky with the loggers with
the death boat yeah that they found you
uh well how did the infection start by
the way I don't know I really don't know
I mean we always have some sort of
little [__] but the thing is now JJ
taught me that there's like three
different trees that can cure infections
I didn't know this at the time I didn't
know the cheat codes now there's there's
if you have a small infection you can
use Sangre de Drago and it'll it'll cure
it right away like let's say you have a
bot fly and it gets a little [__]
there's a fly living in your skin you
put that on there not only will it kill
the fly but it'll heal the infection now
if you have a worse infection you can go
to oh hey which is Ficus insipida and
you can use that and that will
completely heal that will murder it's
like crocodile blood it will murder
infections so like forget Neosporin
that's a joke these are heavy chemical
compounds running through these trees
and they know all about them and so
whatever it is so now at this point
that's no longer an issue like because
we know how to handle it which at that
time if JJ had been there I would have
been fine well learn the hard way so
these are open wounds and then there's
creatures that start living in them is
basically what is it well that's
separate that's bot flies yeah there's
there's a there's a creature that
unfortunately very very very
unfortunately
um likes to make its home inside the
Flesh of mammals yeah and so the Flies
attach their eggs to mosquitoes the
mosquitoes go and seek out warm-blooded
animals the eggs microscopic eggs fall
into your skin and then begin to grow
and sooner or later you feel a twitch
and it's a worm living inside of you
that's like vertical down in you and
it's it's eating you yeah and at first
it's not a problem but when they get to
about as thick as that pen
it starts to hurt because you got a hole
in you and they have a little breathing
tube that comes up and they breathe and
they go back in and then they eat and
they come back up to breathe and you
have a you have a friend living in you
yeah
um and you've had one of those I've had
lots of those it's tough to take them
out
they have hooks
how do you do you have to
you gotta love the junkies so how do you
take it out to come yeah 100 uh you
gotta you gotta put an irritant so like
a lot of times what we'll do down there
is some someone will
take a massive drag of a cigarette and
then they'll spit the they'll they'll
powers like exhale and get some of the
some of the tar which also shows you how
much tar you get out of a cigarette and
then with a knife and you put that right
over the hole and then uh you slap some
Vaseline or something on top of it so
they can't breathe and eventually over
the course of a few hours they'll come
up enough looking for air and then you
got to grab them with the tweezer and
try not to rip them because then you're
gonna get an infection and you gotta
squeeze from the but it's a whole
ceremony when people have bot flies
we're all like oh it's bot fly time
let's go and then like JJ will squeeze
he's got like pliers for thumbs yeah he
can like take a piece of your neck and
you think he's going to break your skin
he'll just squeeze until this thing
comes out
and you don't uh yeah I guess there's an
open wound right there and yeah you
don't want to bathe for a day or two
after until that closes because
otherwise you're gonna have like water
sloshing around in like a little pocket
of yours is kind of gross and that water
might have other organisms in it water
in your skin tends to yeah I mean the
jungle water's clean we drink it like I
drink the water fresh out of the stream
oh that's interesting well it's just a
giant filtration system all those roots
the whole jungle is constantly purifying
everything people might be thinking
about that with the jungle there's
insects probably all over you all the
time
it's not as bad as you think like I've
been to to to to Finland Lapland in the
summer and the mosquitoes are horrendous
like devastating the Amazon in in our
area if you're sitting in a hammock
reading a book
out you know our research Stations don't
have walls or anything
um you're good for about one one
mosquito every half hour which really is
not a lot I mean it's worse in New
Jersey like
it's really not that bad tell me a
little more about the the little baby
anteater Lulu Lulu they they give who
you've rescued and had to sadly leave
behind yeah I just was always fascinated
with giant anteaters or this you know
German Shepherd sized
thing with Wolverine claws and these
giant Popeye forearms and they excavate
ant and Termite mounds and they have
this long tongue
and their babies right on their back for
the first six months of their lives and
so they actually have this incredibly
intimate relationship with their young
and it just so happens that this animal
that I was wildly fascinated with
there was an orphan on the river and JJ
was like you love these things and I was
like yeah and so he went and he was like
hey my friend you should he got he got
me the the baby and we were like we're
gonna rewild her and so I spent like
weeks and weeks and weeks just like with
this thing on my back crawling through
the jungle teaching her to find Ants
giving her milk falling asleep with her
on my chest and their their tongue is
like 11 inches long at that age and so
she when she wanted me to wake up she'd
fire it up my nose and come out my mouth
and she'd and then if I tried to get her
off me quick she'd stick the claws in
and you know all my clothes I have like
I have old like you know now they're
like you know like Museum pieces with
rips in them from from Lulu's claws was
able to also communicate emotion and
feeling and all that she needed it she
needed it so if this animal didn't have
the physical touch if we didn't if I
didn't hold her all day long she throw
Tantrums she'd go shred something she'd
go pull down the curtain she'd go ruin
the woods just should start literally
having a traumatic response to not
having intimacy
which was shocking because again on the
scale of a cockroach to an elephant you
go
I didn't know that giant and theaters
had such intense emotions like
but she did and we we you know and also
taking care of her forced me to
to explore the jungle from the
perspective of an animal
so I got to like be an animal
and so there's only a few times in your
life in my life where I've gotten to do
that you know one was with her another
time was living with a herd of elephants
where I had to walk with them through
the forest and like see how they
interacted
completely natural and it's it's it's
different it's very different and you
realize like just like a person's public
Persona when they're out on the street
in Manhattan is going to be very
different than when you're on the couch
with them on a Tuesday night
and and and with wild animals it's very
much like that you know like if we see
you see a bobcat on a trail and it's
going to look at you and glare at you
and then go off and it's like yeah but
what's it like when it's in the den
that's playing with its Cubs yeah so
that when it's looking at you that's
like the Instagram post it's making and
the actual doctors yeah